[Music]
hi welcome and thanks for joining us you
guys Mary here with my good buddy Mike
mahardy hey hey we're going to play some
zombie mode we're going to play Call of
Duty infinite Warfare zombie mode which
should come out tomorrow um and if you
guys are interested in gam swats
official review that's coming out
tonight but we're just going to play it
for you right now so let's get into it
yeah starting
it
interesting that's not where we should
be it's going to cover up like uh some
important stuff in sent to the
corners just Enemy Number
One oh you're the
geek that's fine that seems reasonable
um I'm also checking out chat if you
guys have questions for uh Mike or
myself we are teamed up in a before I
think the first thing we're going to
do is well we got to survive but yeah
we're also going to be trying to get the
Hasselhoff David Hasselhoff can help you
as an NPC uh so like general for people
that don't play Zombies a lot there's
some like General tips like so right now
we should be letting them tear down
boards before we kill them that's
correct uh so rebuild and get money uh
there's the leaving a crawler at the end
of the rounds if possible that gives you
more time to prep yeah and run around
and do some [__] um you want to like go
for head shot to keep
your keep your ammo handy cuz you need
it right
now so every board you put back on was
that like 10 bucks it's not that much uh
yeah for a while and then if you keep
doing them like they stop giving you
money that adds up
mhm um what do you think about it so far
I played this a couple months ago at uh
Call of Duty like event and I like it a
lot I'm a big zombies fan um I think
I've played all of them since they
started with world of war knock down on
Totten but I really liked du the zombie
Factory I really liked uh Black Ops 3's
first one the uh Noir I forget what it's
called the one with Jeff gold bloom in
them um but yeah it's I'm a fan of this
one I don't have this same Nostalgia for
the ' 80s a lot of people do that was
not alive in the
80s I I think I was alive in the 80s but
I don't think I was able to like do
anything
yeah I think I was just a
WEAU yeah I was
uh negative one so
Let's uh let's overview what we're doing
here we want to open up this area for
anyone who hasn't seen this before if
you want to show them what we're going
to unlock first it's like this place
this is me by the way here wait look at
me a geek with a hey this is me I'm a
big nerd helmet on and yeah well I wish
you could see yourself because you're
dumb and a gan for whatever
reason all right let's
go
suckers get dropped
suckers oh yeah these characters are
good all right so I have enough to open
that if we want to we're trying to
release the Hof is what we're doing
right now but there is a just like all
the other previous all right these are
open if you want to come okay I'm coming
with you just like all the previous cod
zombie modes you have to do everything
in a order of events
I'm checking shat you guys so here is I
believe this is Spencer I can't tell
right now um he's getting the robot head
to bring it back it's kind of like an
omnibot that's right he's going to
attach it to here and then we're going
to get some challenges at the top left
of the screen that we have to
complete
uh
yeah and if we do enough he'll go into
space and bring back down the Hop um all
right this one's actually probably the
hardest one kill 10 jump zombies while
jumping oh damn it yeah it's
it it would help to have the shotgun
over here actually I might do that I'm
going to do that I should have waited
before I made my gun
purchase I always squander my money oh
yeah we need to go find the zombies
though cuz we only have 40 seconds left
[__] so hopefully everybody's doing that
where the [__] are they there's one over
here uh yeah try to kill them all o nice
okay there's one okay I've got oh [__]
that was the last zombie we wasted a lot
of time I thought we' killed them I we
okay so it would have been better toit
do we get a new one or what happens I
think it Cycles through but uh yeah I
mean we kind of jumped the gun on
putting the head on the robot there
without killing the last zombie jump and
kill jump and kill we're not going to do
eight [__] infinite grenade yeah okay
let's wait for the next
one the challenge failed already all
right let's try to I think okay let
let's don't kill as many zombies as
possible right now like avoid them if
possible ah [__] it never mind I just
kill
him it might have to wait till the next
wave I don't know how long it
takes
congratulations it's just configuring
the next
challenge
the music is a good touch in this one
yeah there's a jukebox later on a dance
floor and
whatnot Spencer trying to take my kill
get out of
here um hey can you look at me real fast
a I see you where are you uh over
here to your right there we are care
check this
out oh I put on my shades just doesn't
look doesn't look near nearly as cool to
you
w what are you pressing L1 I picked up
hot Shades 80 Shades doesn't look like
anything to you I thought it would look
like something cool on my eyes but it
didn't all right do not go into Last
Stand sweet so just
survived that's easy enough we can do
it I swear to God if one you go
down I'll be so pissed um so our embargo
on a lot of our opinions of the campaign
and stuff went uh live at 6: a.m. this
morning what do you think so far of the
campaign Mike um oh we can talk about
did it really I thought just like
everything but the review I think is
what we're not allowed to talk about I
am not doing the review I like the
campaign Miguel concepion is doing the
review I like the campaign a whole lot
actually uh if you're if you play every
Call of Duty or if you just played a few
this campaign is not going to be too
familiar to you it does a lot of new
things okay so we got to do three more
challenges this could be
uh yeah this campaign is
actually
pretty original especially for Call of
Duty or just Shooters in general pretty
cool infinity Wards got some like
Naughty Dog Talent there now that wrote
the story Tor kurasaki the nerve
director worked on Uncharted The Last of
Us goes back as far as Crash Bandicoot
but it shows in the story that's cool
multiplayer is uh it's Call of Duty
multiplayer with the the rigs those like
loadouts the classes almost are more
like okay five multi kills use grenades
if possible or a shotgun
uh hopefully they do too like try not to
kill people like One let them Bunch
up all right so Jean Luke just shotguns
guys in the face by themselves don't do
that John Luke stop it if you're
listening stop killing guys by them he's
just blasting regular dudes in the face
I think I need um like a shotgun maybe
or a
grenade here we go here we go nice there
we go one multi-kill H we're not going
to get this one is it the B pretty good
uh that's what I have yeah it's like a
sonic boom shotgun it's pretty cool I
might do
that all right so I don't think we want
to open up a new area
yet that's the best part about these
types of things is you can do things in
different
ways all right here we go oh we don't
need multi kills anymore let see what
the next challenge is uh try to keep as
many alive as possible for the next
challenge
okay uh might get overrun though [__]
all right what we got to do oh I got
hurt
sorry I think I thought I had way more
time than I
did you've killed a lot of zombies this
week between Resident Evil 2 and
this we talk about 28 Days Later
recently on uh
podcast yeah it's been a zombie week
which is great for me cuz I really enjoy
them there's a crawler over here should
I I might just leave him yeah okay melee
Hills oh [__] this going to suck shoot
him in the leg a few
times what that killed him yeah you can
shoot them once in the leg and that's
about
it melee kill 10 of them damn this going
to be
tough we're just going to get
hurt got
hurt there's all right we got eight more
[__] uh you're the only one alive that's
it yeah the
melee screwed us over all right let's do
it again
it's uh we're going going all the way or
bust
yeah all
right I like being the nerd he has a he
looks like Rick Moranis he
does Keys open crates just like they
doing OverWatch or it's hard to play and
read chat but if you guys have questions
I reading chat so throw them to
me let's jump right back in this is not
not like the other Cod games this is a
zombie mode and it's set in the 80s it
is moderately different although yeah
they all have like the same feeling and
Vibe yeah like that's very true I think
my favorite was um I'm like so you to
foret it's called there was this
abandoned tanker in the Arctic with a
Johnny tro mhm makes no sense I realized
that but that it happened
uh who am I now oh I'm the uh the girl
with the leg socks like
leg socks as opposed to as opposed to
arm socks I'm wearing leg socks I'm the
jock yeah you look like Hassel from Far
you're like you're what was ity Steve uh
Steve something from stranger things
yeah I wonder if like [__] Steve I
wonder if like the demograph the main
demographic that plays games now is like
the age that would have 80s
Nostalgia you know I don't know the main
money spending demograph I don't know
but plus well Brian brigh the lead um
the lead designer of zombies in this
just like really likes 80s stuff which I
don't blame him some of these zombies
aren't just like regular 80s Nostalgia
they're like all the way like that one
looks like a Michael Jackson Thriller
jacket yeah like it looks behind all you
I'll scope it
out how did you all get ranked two and I
didn't last time I feel like I did fair
amount of killing well The Score says
differently
[Music]
what would you call these things these
fishnet like gloves I'm wearing arm
stockings where are you well let me look
at my screen I just want to see you oh
on your hands I feel like our characters
would definitely be the ones
dating uh Hey debatable hey I got new
check out my new lipstick I think I can
do
better don't check out my new lipstick
don't your arm down it's hot
think I'm trying to think of like good
80s
lines but I don't really know how girls
got picked up in the
80s hey you nice leg warmers get in get
in my hot ride I think they say that now
too though wonder if disco is dead yet
at this point I think it is
yeah inventory huh damn there's a lot of
stuff to get so those are all like those
side quest things you do here all right
yeah there's so many different things
that we can do besides hle I'm opening
it going to get him all right beginning
of this round we're going to do it right
this time pay attention to that
challenge yo all right and I also don't
want to waste any zombie kills
andun yeah I think the sooner we do it
the better Rob little weird robot
head give us
the Hof all right try to save as many
kills as possible for the
challenge to Zombies From a Distance I
can do that I don't know what a distance
I wonder what what distance they are
referring to uh if they're highlighted
white you're good to kill him I guess
sweet okay this one's simple enough oh
yeah that's not that much distance at
all
actually oh crap I got to change friends
change to the Banshee I think distance
or challenge complete oh I'm going have
to get insta kill oh [__] wait if we get
the challenge with the melee that insta
kill is going to be sick we try not to
get it yet though if we get the in skill
just melee people or use your regular
pistol [__] you okay no okay all right
inst skill use your knife or pistol if
you can but again wait for that next
challenge if possible might be the melee
one oh that was the end round I
shouldn't have got that yet my bad I was
going to
disappear
like why the hell
is us we bu some boards five multi-kills
all right grenades a Shotgun If you have
it yeah just grenades in general would
be great all right well let's let them
pull up a little bit then
yeah I got it
hopefully whoa I just threw it that's
okay
I think it counted there's one yeah got
St sweet all
right that explosion sounded really loud
I don't know if my audio's jacked up hey
damn it we need to consider these a
little bit better we're on the same page
and it's not helping no all right we
only need two more the STX grenad yeah
but we only have 17 seconds yeah
whatever all right I got this one all
right kill him yeah got one more
all right got one hopefully come on yeah
nice all right light them up don't need
we don't need you
anymore all right uh rebuild boards you
can right now they're worth
20 we have to go all the way home what
are you talking about there's boards at
home too
oh uh yeah it might not be worth it at
that point oh yeah you're this dude now
I keep thinking you're
uh you think I'm the nerd still I'm
always still a nerd yeah you
are a cool
nerd all right give us a challenge
Redmond the robot if you're a sunny fan
you know that
reference uh if you guys are just
joining us we're all right melee KS
we're playing Call of Duty infinite
Warfare zombie mode all right like boost
them up okay who is the geek like we're
going for melee kill all right stop for
that what is he doing who is is
this we can do it oh [__] I'm three more
three more we're good I'm getting hurt I
got to back up give me a
second damn it all right insta kill
melee we got insta kill perfect just
melee
good yeah nice that was really that was
lucky
yeah that's all you need
though yeah oh I got Shades the review
will be going up tonight at 9: M someone
just asked
that Call of Duty or Trump I would
probably go with Call of
Duty oh we still have inst Killers so
you know I think yeah we do oh no we
don't not anymore just
disappeared thank you for saving me
there that's fine You' do it for me I
think you could pause the current
challenge yes you can pause which is
weird maybe if you want to wait for an N
skill or
something all right Kill the Zombies
while jumping all right I'm going to get
the shotgun that might help I wonder if
you could throw a grenade and then as
it's about to blow up jump you think
that help yeah I think as long as you're
in the air when said zombo dies yeah W
clowns what yeah the exploding clowns
that's the that's like the Boss Wave of
this the mini boss wave all right um
shotguns are helping I mean the clowns
are actually good because they blow up
yeah all right yeah sweet okay this is
good this is
good two three more all oh God just make
sure you jump cuz if you they blow up so
they're you're going to get like two
kills every time you jump any more come
on 18 seconds I hear them I hear their
noses
nice got it sweet we're close to hassle
off we got like a couple more
challenges oh God do you have a do you
have an aversion of clowns or are you
cool with them no I do
now they're
terrifying like those ones that were
recently like luring kids into the woods
what yeah you didn't hear about that
like well I heard that they were clowns
but I don't I don't remember I remember
weird clowns in the woods I remember
seeing like a news article about a
creepy clown I mean luring kids is a
misleading cuz what kid loves clowns
like that all right um we got one more
challenge hopefully one more maybe two
all right sweet we got a new area if you
want to come over here um do not go last
all right just survive I hear the clown
for 1 minute don't go
down we have a lot more space to run I
think Spencer or on Luke opened up more
area more space for us [__] where's that
get
that all right this is going to suck
because sweet oh that was perfect good
timing for the challenge cuz we're
toward the end of the round so we got
some Breathing Room could really use a
better gun what do we got what do we got
this SMG over here is good right where I
am the E it I don't know if in the
campaign if you press down it switches
to a shotgun that's weird um press press
down on the d-pad yep okay we not in
Zombies all right P [__] I'm not paying
attention stick to oh instant kill [__]
yeah all right just use your worst
weapon I don't know if we want to risk
using knives we're almost done with the
challenge come
on [__] you that robot toally [__] yeah
oh the robot it's happening let's go to
the robot where's he at he's he was over
here is he in the normal area where he
was already he's here wait let's do it
before he's over
here wait where are you at I'm over here
um in the previous area yeah do it Blast
Off
yeah give us hle that was so [__] oh
[__] Are we still V kill no not at all
no where are you girlfriend damn it I'm
down okay let's not die let's you hassle
off I'm coming I'm com don't worry about
me they just or don't try to get me yet
there's too many all right someone's
getting
me yeah we're good all right observe the
Hof where's he at he's here
wait do you see him yeah oh he looks
like kit from Night Rider too yeah
that's what I'm that's what we need this
is what we needed yeah he's got an EAD
[__] yeah he's so cool look at that [__]
oh my God that's so cool we trying you
two just charging oh my God same gun
trying to determine look how cool look
look at the eyebrow look at the chest
hair
yeah this zombie running over a zombie a
he's got some Levis we're trying to
determine if like how much they paid
Hasselhoff to be in the game or if like
he paid them because he knew it would be
awesome uh yeah we had Infinity Ward
recently and he they said when he went
into the studio it was like their the
best day of their
lives cuz like Conor McGregor is briefly
in the campaign kit Harrington plays a
big part
so what now like where do you go from
hassle I kind stream's all downhill I
kind of want to show people the dance
floor um actually yeah let's do that we
have enough money yeah let's start
making our way over this way okay can do
the zombie dance it's like a lethal
dance
floor it's over toward polar Peak we got
to go through there you want to come
this way all
right
they climb up on the over the railing
yeah all right let's do I got some money
you got some money honey got donate
donate another thousand oh I have a lot
um I can do it no I got it I got a lot
of
money I'm filthy
rich this place is I like this map a lot
just like it makes sense well it doesn't
make sense cuz it has to just came from
space but you know what I mean all right
sweet I'll go with the
this oh I'm sorry throw Mary hold
triangle when you get the chance
obviously it's not imperative right now
cuz
you're hold it it didn't do anything uh
it made me reload cuz that's how you
never mind that's how you oh did it
change yeah I thought it was down on the
d-pad it it cign you can do either did
it change for you or no cuz this goes
into like submachine gun
mode uh it goes into my pistol okay
never mind he that gun doesn't have the
oh Hasselhoff are you still okay can he
die I don't know I hope like in real
life where's this uh dance Flor I
thought it was this way I could be wrong
though this looks like a good place to
hold out up here if we want oh
[__] this place is very without the
power oh they're coming out of this
window
oh he's so [__] cool he is
cool I don't think anybody would ever
deny that so cool anecdote from Infinity
Ward I guess they were like trying to
get him to come promote stuff with them
at uh Gamescom and he's not too familiar
with the Video Game World so he's like I
don't know where does that take place
and they're like uh Germany so he's like
are you kidding me they love me there
like yeah I know you're from Germany or
you're German sorry I don't I don't
really know where it's from La
maybe but I a [__] I'm down guys this
isn't looking
good don't worry about me yet well
actually yeah you can get me that' be
great
ooh I think more importantly [__]
they're dropping from the [__]
ceiling oh
[__] okay so the DJ's over here I so
Hasselhoff is usually at that DJ the
turntable over here so I wonder what
happens if he's already helping
us can open this door how much money do
I have I'll open this one let's do this
I thought you wanted the I don't know
where the dance Flor is actually Spencer
would probably be the one who knows see
look there's another
Hasselhoff do we still have
ours I hope we still have ours where'd
he go or did he die
no talk to the
DJ wait I'm going to turn up his audio
listen to am I get turned into some
walking
meat coming you got to commit man come
back when you have all the parts we need
parts God damn it
h ooh that's a good
song
you put that gameplay down a little bit
sure well obviously I want I wanted to
hear the Hof that was all no it's good
uh yeah I was just blaring destroying my
ears [__]
[__]
yeah insta
kill use your melee through the park and
ripping arms from holy [__] what is this
there's a giant alien ogre uh holy [__]
it's not an alien it's a it's definitely
something insta kill is not working oh
I'm down I'm down too [__] I'm in
trouble oh we still have any
skill I thought it
wasn't
crap all right I'm not going to waste
anyo on him I'll kill the regular
grunts oh instant kill's gone
oh my God he's shooting he's got a laser
he's a that's how I got down I was
wondering what
happened happened really fast guys I
think I'm dead that happened really
quickly please don't you have any
decency all right I'm going to the
arcade actually this might be cool to
show people uh afterlife arcade you play
some games to earn a self-revive token
uh skall no let's play Let's Play
totally not the
mall let's play this black hole what's
the deal with black hole tickets I like
totally I don't tickets what is
this I cannot believe someone's still
alive I think it's it's got to be
Spencer why can't I do anything
here the
[__] yes so these are all Activision
games actually this makes sense not
bad all right well that was Hasselhoff
in Call of Duty infinite Warfare zombie
mode which is something I never thought
I'd say got the itch ask is Ron Jeremy a
playable character H despite the fact of
his popularity in the 80s he's not in
this
game
and um I didn't see a Michael Jackson
but I did see his jacket from Thriller
uh yeah just go again I go what time is
it it's uh 11:30 oh okay cool in the
a.m. we go until like noon let's do
it why not just have a standalone cod
zombie game you know there's enough fans
of the zombie mode that they probably
could but I think they use it as fod for
well I I have friends that just play
zombies so they buy this
Call of Duty is
a but yeah that'd be cool to be able to
download it by itself
but tell me more about the
cards uh I mean they just function like
burn cards if you played like Titanfall
or like earlier zombies I
guess like um you just use them like to
Ian you pick them up but there's that
machine in the next area where you like
use them they just give you Buffs
boring it oh I'm the jock now who are
you I'm the cool hip dude where are you
oh no you're not yeah I'm I'm not the
girl or the boy I'm a I'm we we could
date these I'm like the Run DMC guy I
would date that guy I would date you
yeah all right here we go oh whoever
that is has that area locked down all
right I'll get these
guys
oh that dude had a Michael Jackson
jacket on look it look it look it look
it yeah I'm telling you there's you said
that already didn't you there's Thriller
stuff and I think there's probably I
wouldn't be surprised if there was like
um Back to the Future type stuff like
there's
hidden here's a here's references
everywhere I'm going to say something
controversial I think the music video
for U beat it is better than
Thriller for very different reasons
Thriller is obviously like production
Valu is through the roof it's very good
it's like that's a short film it's a
film like what's your but beat it just
the energy of it like they're [__]
dance fighting but then they resolve
their issues through dance and then they
start dancing together stop it that's
why that's why music exists in the first
place to like that stop are you telling
me to stop the woman
oh oh I love that there's actually an
animation for them pulling off each
board instead of just like flaing their
arms and the boards come off that person
just jumped to get that high board yeah
over what are you doing what are you
doing I have have this window locked
down I have this window locked down I
was like lady who is that lady get out
of here who hey Spencer or Jean Luke in
the bullpen we're going to have a few
words if you keep taking my kills when
we're done with the
stream you know I don't threaten I make
promises no just kidding but seriously
stay away from my Windows you have
Windows no I have one window I'm very
proud of
it it really help our full press if we
had the power oh he uses Sports
metaphors are we doing more
H I'm yeah why not I'm done all right
I'm going to get his head
unless Spencer might already be on the
way once I find out oh who is that who
is that it is Jean Luke of course it is
stupid look at it that's why he has 1300
points he not a team player you you this
isn't just about being a team player
it's about
winning it's mostly about being it's
mostly
about oh
[__] all right robot head has been
connected oh this is the old school M1
you can't reload it manually I remember
metalon front line like that you had to
like just shoot oh 10 zombies while
jumping oh [__] I should get the Banshee
but it's not oh wait yeah all right cool
should be able to do it now seven
zombies inst a kill [__] yeah that's
perfect uh jump and shoot him with a
pistol I
guess nice is that all of them where
they
at
how long do you have insta
kill come on hurry up uh we have like
once the wave starts 15 seconds to kill
them while jumping uh insta kill it
shows up next to the scene three thing
at the top right as long as that skull
is there which it's going away [__]
hurry up hurry up hurry up just do it
quickly we have 16
seconds uh yeah three more G there's
none over here here they
come
okay or stop doing that who is
this oh man what's wrong they didn't
jump I had it I had it and they took it
and I'm Mary I get testy when when H
enters the
picture it'll work out we get more
challenges we get more opportunities to
solve
this but it does get harder over
time I think that's what you kind of
need team chat on like we can only talk
to each other
mhm so I didn't think you guys wanted
four people talking on the stream no not
at
all all right melee kills so we've had a
bunch of Shooters coming out they're all
super different mhm they're all good too
which one do you like the most ooh
Titanfall 2 but Battlefield is really
good oh insta kill perfect we've been
getting lucky with that uh melee kill
six zombies um Call of Duty like I said
uh I don't know how much I can talk
about my impressions of it but it's very
different in its own way it's I enjoyed
my time with it um we still have four
zombies to
melee we have time we got a minute left
insta kill should last until for
four it's already starting to
go it's gone am I using a bottle a
broken bottle all right we'll just just
shoot him a few times
am damn
it stop
it stop all right one more one
more I'm [__] down from trying to
melee
sorry card selection all right I'll
select a card shop class scorching skin
Mana up eagley
nade party all right scorching skin
sounds sweet let's do that so I just
activated a card next 10 enemies who
damage me will burn cool how long does
that last or is it just until it's out
good question I do not know uh until
it's out oh yeah actually it's it
doesn't run out through time it runs out
like until 10 enemies or whatever the
next 10
enemies uh what is that
[__] infinite ammo just light them up 12
zombies from a distance from a
distance damn uh we got 50 seconds we're
good can I deposit money what is this
going to do let's try that
out this is giving me
points that's
weird maybe he just wants to kill us why
the hell would he want to do that hurry
up
two more ah we're good we got 20 seconds
[__] sweet got it cool good job I need
another
gun wait for the next
challenge a he burned did it happen yeah
it's pretty cool all right I'm just kind
of waiting for this ch to kill people
well this can't do it
forever yeah they're
they're it's going to be like kill
multiple yeah totally you
just multi- kills [__] all right saw
that coming wait wait wait here's two in
a
row nice that's one no it didn't work H
someone got one infinite grenades sweet
Just Launch them oh [__] they got but
they got to be together yeah I [__] that
up all right These Guys these guys cook
it off and then
bam wait wa wait wait let's get these
together there are these two people
together got it uh one more [__] that's
the end of the wave uh 30 seconds no
someone got it sweet I thought that was
the end of the wave nice it worked out
uh maybe three more challenges we're
good two
more for those that have weren't there
when we did earlier we're doing these
challenges to get this robot to blast
off into space yep go to who knows where
and grab David Hasselhoff and bring him
back down he is an alien after all I
swear I'm not making any of that up all
right
hows how do you activate your card uh
hold L1 and R1 at the same time and you
can change which one you use by pressing
down on the
d-pad
all right just survive don't go into
Last Stand which the clowns complicate
that with the explos explosions we can
do
it I feel really good about
this oh God they're [__]
horns yeah their
no no it's so
upsetting
all right should be
it it's going very
well I foresee new card nade party
infinite oh actually I should wait I'm
going to wait till the next challenge to
see what we could use in terms of burn
cards there nade party that will help
with the
multi-kills H we I think we've seen all
the challenges by now I think they've
been repeating every time not repeating
but I don't think we've seen anything
new in a while that's true let's try to
get to the dance floor this time uh yeah
actually Spencer would be the one to
follow cuz I I think he knows where he's
listening probably
not you guys saw
little people seem to always get
frustrated that Cod is like the same
game every year do you think like this
one does anything different yeah totally
the campaign is like the most original
in Call of Duty uh the structure of it
the seamless like space Jackal space
fights uh Jack multiplayer is not crazy
different do you want to go to the new
area sure we're almost done oh kill a
zies while jumping I was not paying
attention all right sweet let's do
that it's three we're almost
there oh [__] wrong button nice whoever
did
that sweet got it all right we should
have off all right where's the robot
somebody press him touch his
buttons where'd he go I don't know I'm
covered in Zombies I got to worry about
my life currently
oh someone got him oh
[__] don't forget to survive in addition
to enjoying the
ha all
right come on David where you at boy boy
he's coming he's coming he's
coming don't you worry about
that yeah yeah Kip from Night Rider
let's see
it he has the best intra wait put time
to go the oh no David you devil
distracting
us with your magical eyes and your firm
jaw and your Grizzly chest hairs all
right okay see nine Let's uh let's move
on I don't know like Spencer if you're
listening I'll let you lead the way cuz
you know where the dance oh I think he's
doing it already Sweet is he the Lady or
the I
don't no Spencer is uh the nerd the nerd
got
it got enough money to go to the next
area too yeah I'm
loaded although I would like a different
gun he's another EAD I might get the
EAD all right so Spencer's going this
way
wo I'm always open to
Contra he's talking about contracts he's
doing business even in a zombie invested
World he's practical figuring out how to
make shutter following Spencer Spencer
seems to have a mission that I'm going
to all right I'm going to I will join
you guys I'm
coming oh
[__] [__] we should leave that crawler
there's one right next to you uh yeah oh
never mind we cannot someone got a nuke
uh uh all right we're just spens up here
all right let's follow him let's go to
the dance party Moonlight Cafe
no oh was he doing the pack-punch
ininal FM damn he got a good gun
actually that was the
scar don't worry honey I ain't let any
of us go down like
that
oh
oo some blue flames
so so this is a random weapon box or
what it used to be
sweet come on what this oo here we
go good shot oh [__] there's a giant
dude up here this is really concerning
he's about to shoot his laser too he
sure
is I'm not even hurting should we leave
this area oh you got to shoot him in the
head right now probably yeah yeah
there's not much room to run this is
dangerous oh God I'm going to go down
this is a bad
area I'll try to get you no take no
don't worry about it me don't worry
about
me this is no time to
revive ah his laser got me oh we're all
down that's the best we've done I think
no I think we can do better than
that man that was a good round yeah it
was pretty good let us let us do one
more all
right do you want to go for the Hoff one
more time or you want to go do something
else let's try to do something else okay
what do you want to do I don't know I
don't know where the dance floor is
maybe Spencer know I don't know we'll uh
figure it out
mhm let's just get let's just do it
feels good we could go a different way
although I like that Wheel of Fortune
that's like the random weapon box um
what are the tickets for uh the
afterlife uh arcade there might be other
uses but that's what how I understand it
oh goo said go Hof the
charts that's pretty good well that's
what Hoff said when he came down it's
pretty good don't credit goo I'm going
to credit him
I'm the nerd this time you're a
lady I definitely know a lady when I see
one zombies worth it JJ Hart asks um if
you like zombie mode this is everything
that you can remember about Call of Duty
zombie mode plus some added benefit of
an a pretty sick
80s backdrop um David Hasselhoff David
Hasselhoff fistic weapons um 80s music
in frame it's a pretty good de blend of
things you love and some new stuff this
guy's hair is
sick
and or are these going to get ripped out
in like 5
Seconds
it's time for the next
round you guys all buy a gun immediately
I always use my starting pistol for the
beginning I use the starting pistol but
I get the gun so like once we go we can
just go
M plus there's some decent guns up
here [__] all right I'm going to kill
him let the other down
board just die
be
all right doing pretty good
bewhere we have enough money to leave if
you want to let's do one more wave
okay
let's see that face what other games
have amusement parks Left 4 Dead
one was it the first Left 4 Dead I think
it's two no two yeah you go from the
mall
to man Left 4 Dead those games are
good yes they
are this I wish you could come over here
and see her can you come over here real
fast uhhuh uh quickly yeah she looks so
[__] vile I just want you to see her
I'm over here I'm I'm the nerd I'm over
here check her out so she's got like
this little bikini top on and some leg
warmers I shot her in the head and she's
like and dead super gross
looking all right sweet let's go she's
ready to party basically I'm going let's
go who's
who's I don't know I don't even want to
worry about the Hof this time no what do
you want to go for then I don't know
let's go explore more let's go the other
way like this way where uh Spencer is
yeah all right follow follow follow the
dude in the jumpsuit I will I'm going to
follow jumpsuit man I'm just going to
open it [__] it let's go oh you have to
donate Whoever has thousand I have
it all right let's go
I feel like the dance would be obvious
what it what building it would be in all
right so he wants to go here mhm okay so
I don't have the cash NE do I all right
looks like nobody does so let's just
hold up here and make money
honey all right nade party Eagle ey
let's do eagley see what that does okay
sniper rifle hits are always CR I don't
have a sniper rifle I wish I knew what
that was all right sweet so in the
future don't use that if I don't sniper
can I find one maybe that' be pretty
sweet just every hit is a head
shot nothing nothing nothing oh [__]
wonder if it gives you the money for a
head shot as well not just the
effect I would assume it would all right
I've got enough money but like a better
weapon yeah I
understand um how much is it oh I do not
have it's 1500 I have 12 I have 13
um I'll do it um in the next round and
you can buy a better gun I'm fine with
that wait what gun do you have no we
have like the same level of gun that's
fine doesn't matter just protect me
until I get enough money oh someone took
one for the team sweet it was pretty
boy oh this is a good gun on the vulk
it's clown clown round I'm backing up
backing the [__]
up [__] that was really
close
oh that clown came out of
nowhere came in my life and changed is
there a mystery weapon box uh yeah we
just we did it last it's the Wheel of
Fortune now we it's uh I mean if it's
like a mystery weapon box then it's
going to be uh oh Spencer's going
somewhere cool it's going to be random
location oh [__] sorry Spencer uh all
right sweet what's he doing what's this
lever he's also uh Cyrus Drake uh I'm
looking at all chats I look at twitch
and uh YouTube and
gamespot.com but I'm also playing so I'm
trying to do a deaf blend of play and
read chat so uh Cyrus I'm on let's
follow I'm on Twitch right now so if you
have a question throw it in the chat oh
bumper cost what can we get in oh it
hurt you it hurt
him wait how what the all right let's
get off these are going to infite ammo
nice max ammo
sorry jeez I can't believe watch out for
rogue bumper cars what are the tickets
for again uh the afterlife arcade when
you die you go in there you have a
chance to just self-revive what's
this okay so use the tickets in the
arcade so this maybe this is the okay
does anybody have 1250 yes you want to
open this you happens he seems he seems
to be telling us to go in there he seems
to he seems for us to want to go in here
oh y wait where's the where's the uh SK
ball all right I'm going to just again
follow Spencer he seems to be the man
with a plan I'm in
trouble I was trying to play ski ball I
got
hurt all right where'd he go where's he
going
oh yeah put your dancing shoes
on wait I want to see the zombies dance
let's try to let him get on there okay I
think they dance I don't know if I want
to be standing on it though I think it's
like pretty dangerous wa oh
my are they on
there yeah
yes yeah get after it they're oh my God
wait so do they not hurt
you nope uh I think they die at the end
maybe not or I don't know should we just
light them up we could put a Grenade on
there but I'm really enjoying it like
visually I'd like to just yeah he got
the
oh
[Applause]
yeah oh my God I'm Reviving my
buddy that was awesome I wonder how much
that cost he he pressed it over
here look I'm playing basketball they're
playing basketb like Mike really they're
playing basket classic early 2000s need
stop playing oh I'm I'm in
trouble
no regrets no
regrets play some bball what's in
here nade
party your grenade slot will generate
over time
sweet let's just [__] light [__]
sorry got the N4 here we go where'd he
go I'd really like O Come Through The
Warp portal to your oh we're back in the
beginning
yeah hey
go back through nah got to enter it
somewhere
else so where are we going I don't know
I'm liking this zombies though follow
pants suit man dance for
again all right well get a few bucks
quick I'd like a
better we're going we going somewhere
else okay uh yeah we can go toward the
Wheel of Fortune if it is in the same
spot every time I'm like the mystery box
rotates you know you're
zombies all right I donated $1,000 over
here I need more here you
go more damn you did instant kill let's
melee some
dudes oh [__] I slapped her yeah
I slapping a zombie to death is feels
really good I got like a hook in my
glove in your fishnet yeah
uh we still have one hit so go for
it it's almost gone it's almost gone oh
my God I want to go down this slide
really bad can you come
here oh I don't know can I open this uh
you probably can from up top oh I really
wanted that I think that's where the
Wheel of Fortune is
actually I think it's all I've ever
wanted I've got a th again we can
probably go through that let's go oh my
God little slide
all right let's
go it's good Escape Route I guess uh
this way through here no it's the
bathrooms the bathrooms all right I'll
open this let's go to the
bathrooms oh a shortcut yes yes oh this
is The Wheel of Fortune and the power
okay there's The Wheel of Fortune so
through here no concessions big old
burrito big old omelet because the um
that giant guy is going to show up
pretty soon
remember yeah and we remember we don't
want to do it from here cuz this part's
too hard yeah where's this can you go on
the slide over that bridge maybe from
the I man there's so much to do there's
so many activities taking my
head uh oh the they stay active these
cards that's cool I thought they would
replace each other they
stack this looks cool I'm going to press
this and see what happens when I have
money
[__] oh there's a thanks save my
life there's just so many things to put
your money in it's
like it's just which one you want to
do Hoff or dance party mhm mhm all
viable
options
Carpenter
um I picked up some
money all
right I think that giant zombie guy
should be coming out pretty soon I feel
like we're at that wave
alien cuz it was like two or three after
clown he just pressed this what does
this do
who he got sucked in
D oh my God yeah get after
it that's so rewarding that's what we
need wait it's not going to suck me in I
hope oh look at that
idiot oh
man um I need a I really use is a better
gun let's
go there got to be some other cool stuff
we can do burn damn that was rad bomb
Stoppers what's
this explosions won't get me down all
right let's uh I'm going to do the wheel
of Forge and see what gun I get quick
all right I where was it I'm fairly
confident that this will be the round no
I think it's usually wave 10 that's the
one we never get past or no we did last
one all right oh quick quick quick quick
quick quick quick give me something
good all right off yeah
a
whoa what
damn
honey all right I got a good gun but I
died Michael Jackson is Out For Blood
here you all right let's be smarter
about this I'll give you in a second
whoever that
is
oh I just hit myself with my own grenade
almost I got you
nice where's that where's that thing got
a power generator all right let's see
what this let's oh this thing just like
blows people up I really need a new gun
oh this thing's good I'm going to save
it for that giant through
though here we go
it's just a power generator that I don't
know really [__] up they're coming
through the bar
too
unfortunate
all
[Music]
right where they going I got this thing
for the yeah let's follow cuz remember
we don't want to take out the uh main
dude there who is this what's going on
here shooting range huh all right let's
play Let's play
this shouldn't somebody be killing
zombies yeah but see what we get from
this oh should have shot him oh [__]
there's like serious
exploding clowns you got you guys take
care of those I'm I'm doing God's work
dude the
clowns see what I got what did I get
nothing just tickets are you kidding
me oh ooh I feel like you're not taking
taking the clowns seriously enough
they're look at them they're exploding
how do you how do you take this
seriously well oh man I'm I'm low on
ammo and the only other gun I have is
all right I guess I'll use this oh let's
go in this
thing what is that uh E I think I don't
want to waste I oh [__] I'm down oh I'm
down too what happened hard clowns
killed us is it cuz we went in the mouth
no I don't think so there they bunched
up I don't know actually good question
three clown in a row this could be it
for us we just
died how do we get three Downs all at
once damn
it seems harder than usual zombies in
general or am I wrong here that say it's
about the same level of difficulty yeah
that was the furthest scene I think we
got was 10 I think we got past 10 the
first time but I don't know anyway was a
good round for me sweet all right that
was fun
into it yeah I wonder if that mouth
closed on us I think the I think the
clown just blew up I do think that we
should 100% have a hoverboard I didn't
see any hoverboards did you pretty sweet
are you going to go through all the
weapons uh n all right I just unlocked a
couple I just wanted to see let's see
what you have going on here
uh yeah this is the progression I don't
know there's so much to unlock there and
we've basically just barely scratched
the surface um but that is an overview
of Call of Duty infinite Warfare zombie
mode those are the first 10 scenes and a
look at the Hof and a dancing floor um
we have a so much coverage on Gamespot
right now and on our YouTube page for uh
Call of Duty um we're going to show how
to get the Hoff uh in a video form as
well as our initial impressions of the
campaign and of Hoff and then our full
review goes live at 9:00 p.m. tonight by
Miguel conceps a new documentary going
up starting today and we have a behind
the scenes documentary where we actually
like talk to the devs and uh show you
way more behind the scenes of how Call
of Duty is made so lots of stuff to
check out on Gamespot and then the full
game goes live uh tomorrow cool so you
guys can check that out thank you guys
for watching and we'll see you guys
again next
time